hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the 1971 candidate series its
nickname Petros and again against Bobby
Fischer this is game 8 and if you've
been following the series so far
official one game one Petros and quickly
retaliated in game 2 with the white
pieces then three games were drawn and
then Fischer won two games in a row so
even though if you check out only the
first five games it seems like Petrosyan
was in the lead in pretty much all of
them except that quick draw but then
even even in Game six he chose a very
passive passive approach that ready
opening which Fischer took very nicely
advantage of and managed to win the game
and then again Game seven truly a
brilliant positional masterpiece by
Bobby Fischer then this brings us to
game 8 now Petrosyan is down two points
in the match and now he can't afford
pretty much can't afford any more draws
he just has to get back into this match
so what did he prepare for this game for
this game's Petrosyan opens a with d4 to
get in the mood here is the photo of
this matchup as you can see Pat Rosen
again posing as we've already seen in
the previous video there we have it and
Fischer to this d4 move of course as
usual replies with Knight to f6
we have c4 e6 knife to f6 and the d5
here we transpose into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to c3 and now c5 this
very nice starter set up we have III and
again petrosal chooses this sort of a
sort of a team opening line with III and
again Fischer will take advantage of
this very nicely as you'll see nice to
see six we have a three and now nice to
e4 and here Queen to c2 but Rosen
doesn't want to exchange in the center
with C captors on d5 usually this will
be a theme in many openings it's often
he who trades first is pretty much a
giving advantage to the other player as
it is often said in chess to take is a
mistake if there's if you're not really
gaining anything by capturing you know
just don't capture that's okay but Rosen
keep the tension in the center going we
have night captures on c3b characters on
c3 and Bishop to e7 Bishop to b2 we have
castles and now Bishop to d3 so if you
look at this dark square bishop here
it's not really an excellent Bishop but
just yet it's pretty much like a pawn so
again patrols and choose is a very
passive opening and he has to do
something about this h6 as the h7 pawn
was under attack we have castles and now
Knight to a5 are pressuring the c4 pawn
and again Petrosyan is reluctant to
capture on d5 instead he defends the
point Knights the d2 we have seek after
Sun D captures on c4 Knight captures on
c4 Knight captures on c4 Bishop captures
on c4 and now b6 Fischer prepares to
develop his light square Bishop and
pressure the White King will have e for
Bishop the b7 and now Queen to e2
guarding de to pawn from here it would
be very dangerous to play a move
something like e 5 as danger lurks in
the position here b5 would be an
excellent move for example bushel
captures captures captures and now Queen
d5 a simple idea threatening checkmate
but as White has to deal with this you
will simply win a piece here it's okay
Queen - E - we have roped the c8
x-raying that bishop on c4 we have brush
up to B 3 and now b5 a very nice move
which prevents the immediate d5 because
of c4 with c4 you would pretty much
cement and this Bishop to behave like a
pawn for the rest of the game after
Bishop to see - you can capture capture
on d5 and now after look after d1 rook
e8 and the black black would be better
here so after b5 Pettersson goes f4 we
have Queen to b6 and now King to h1
simply getting the King out of the way
as the Queen was eyeing him seek after
sandy 4c chapters on d4 and now b4 again
a very nice move Fischer could have
prepared it with a 5 but he doesn't
think it's necessary by playing before
he's not threatening Bishop to a sixth
win the exchange here Albert okay a
capture some before simply grabbing upon
now ruku
rook and queen guard da six squares so
bishop tray sex is no longer possible
Bishop captures son before was played if
you try something like Quinn capture son
before with an attack on the bishop
simply rook to f3 defends the bishop and
also it it's a nice rook lift so this
only favours white so after a capture
some before but should capture some
before and now we have d5 push up the c3
by Fischer Bishop captures rook captures
and now you have to do something with
the bishop and this is pretty much well
we could say the the more important
moment in the game because here if
Petrosyan was not down by two points in
the match it would most likely play
Bishop to a2 and then let's say bunch of
to a6 attacks the Queen and the rook we
have Queen moves with an attack on the
rook rook to d3 now attacking the Queen
and now Queen to f2 offering a trade of
Queens captures on d5 commercial
captures rook captures opening up an
attack against the rook on f1 Queen
captures pawn captures and now after
rook captures on a6 rook to b5 and we
would have a completely equal position
and material-wise on the board to Brooks
and the four pawns each where Fischer
would have a passed pawn on the Queen
side but pretty much a drawn endgame and
pretty most likely this is what
Petrosian would have gone for if he was
not already down in this match but as a
draw with the white pieces doesn't
really suit him he goes Bishop Bishop to
c2 and decides to sacrifice a pawn so
okay he captures on d5 Fischer accepts
the pawn sacrifice and now comes c5 so
okay you did give up a pawn but what
what do you get in exchange Fischer
plays rook to e3 with an attack on the
Queen of course he wants to push the D
pawn but if you push the d4 immediately
you can get blocked with Bishop to d3
and then this Queen Bishop battery will
be a very nice blockade against the d4
pawn
so first rook to e3 attacking petrow
since Queen we have Queen to d2 and only
now d4 now Bishop to d3 isn't all that
impressive
simply Queen to c6 you're threatening
checkmate here well first first
capturing the bishop and then delivering
checkmate so this bishop would now
only serve as a target so after d4 rook
a to be one attacking in Fishers queen
we have Queen to a6 eyeing that rockin
f1 look to f2 getting out of the way and
also introducing another defender of the
G to pawn we have looked to d8 by
Fischer and now comes King to g1 a very
important move as the back Patersons
back rank is very vulnerable for example
if you try something like rook to d1
with ideas of capturing here black
doesn't really care simply push up to e4
and now even if you try to give up the
Queen for all this material it doesn't
really help you d captures rook captures
with check King moves you even capture
the miserable with check in g6 and even
though you have two rooks and a bishop
for the Queen you're lost your look is
under attack you can't really move the
rook away from the F file because Queen
to have Queen to f1 will result in
checkmate and of course you can't allow
black to capture your look so if you
play something like rook to f3 again you
will face Queen to a-1 check and then
now after you give up all the material
rogue d1 check Queen captures rook f1
you will still be given Queen to f1
checkmate
so after rook to d8 we have Tim to g1
kind of trying to make it the back rank
a bit more or less vulnerable Bishop to
g4 attacking the bishop Bishop captures
rook captures and do now h3 Petrosyan
makes some breathing space for the king
d3 of course you have to push her past
pawn rook the b3 introducing another
attacker into the game Quintus e4
attacking the rook rook goes back and
the now rook D to d4 with a triple
attack against the f4 pawn
Petrosyan defense at g3 and the now rook
to d5 Fischer now wants to either trade
off one of the rooks or gain control of
the B file King to h2 by petrosyan and
now rook to b5 here if you if you trade
rook captures Queen captures so White's
still pretty much caught up defending
against this detour opponent Fischer can
simply start pushing his a pawn so white
has nothing to look for here so after
work to b5 t1 tries rope to a to getting
draw card
and also perhaps attacking the a 7-point
about Fisher ignores it da 7-point is no
longer important as Fisher now gained
control of the B file rope to be won by
Fisher and now comes g4 there really
isn't time to capture here because here
look to eat you would have would have
been enough to win this game you have to
capture or otherwise you're going to
lose the rope if you move the Queen so
rook captures pawn captures and now
whatever you do even this check doesn't
really do anything engage 7a White has
no means of continuing his attack and
black will simply bring another Queen
into the game and checkmate white king
okay rook to be one g4 now by Petrosyan
kind of now we have rook to e2 all the
same rook to e2 capturing D captures an
e2 and now Queen captures an e2 here for
a brief moment
Petrosyan manages to you know regain the
material balance on the board but it's
far too late the Queen captures an f4
with check we have King to g2 this is
move 40 by patrols and so time control
has been reached and for Fischer's 40th
move he plays rook to b3 and here in
this position Tigran Petrosian resigned
the game so what if you resign well
there are simply too many threats here
for example you can pause the video for
example if y if patron would play Queen
to have to offer up Queen trade you can
try and figure out how black wins here
so pause the video here and try to find
any any sequence of moves that are
sufficient to win for black so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
in-game finisher and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show well for
example Queen to e4 check now as the
Queen moved from the defense of this
pawn you will simply check the king and
now if King to h2 you simply grab the e5
pawn and if for example King to g1 then
rook the b1 check is coming king h2 now
you can even give Queen to h1 check King
moves rook the b3 check King moves g5
check has the Queen is controlling this
diagonal you have to go up with the king
and now you play Queen to c6 and there
is no defense against Queen to g6
checkmate or if you push ecigs then okay
Queen to e6 will be
checkmate but it's checkmate just the
same as f-4s is guarded here so
Petrosyan isn't interesting in exploring
all of this these fancy lines so after
rook to b3 he decided to resign the game
so this is a game number 8 of the 1971
candidates match Bobby Fischer vs.
Tigran Petrosian Fischer now won his
third game in a row and he's now leading
this match by 3 points so now if he
gains one more point then the match will
be over as now the result is five and a
half to two and a half in Fischer's
favor so if he touches six and a half
the match is over but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you're enjoying the Fischer series so
far as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
with another interesting video and then
you know some some more interesting
content hopefully I think you'll and
I'll see you soon